This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Christina.
All right.
Gina?
Nomadic gene SARS.
Gotcha.
Really?
I do it when I'm tired.
My vision gets worse.
Worse or why worser?
Yeah.
No.
I noticed you said you had some farks building.
Why is that?
Because you gave me a really heavy Veggie Omelet.
Scrambled,
I should say.
It's the pregnancy scramble.
It's going to make both of us dub.
Yeah.
You said you'd been struggling more since.
It's hard.
There's a,
there's a time when your intestines just get pushed all the way up.
You know what?
I tried though the squatty potty today and that actually really helped.
What about anal?
What do you think that'll help?
I know.
I kind of want to stick my hand.
If you ever have the impulse to put your finger in your butt hole to pull out
the Ph.
The Turd.
No,
I do.
I just,
his imagination.
I want,
you want me to put a little toy in there for you?
I mean,
that could help.
Why not?
Oh,
I'm so against that.
Try it out.
I was so afraid of that.
Would you let me do that to you?
Yeah.
Try it out and let you try it out.
Sure.
Beads.
Why not?
Oh,
you were told lie.
I'm serious.
High Line in these people.
I would let you do it.
No you wouldn't.
Should we do it for your birthday tomorrow?
That is my birthday.
You're right.
Happy born day.
Tom.
I'm going to be 49 um,
yeah,
I think so.
How do you feel about your smurf day?
Um,
I feel pretty great about it.
I'm excited.
39 I know.
Can I even 40 yet?
I know,
I know.
Gross.
You're not even a person.
You don't think I'm a person yet.
Now 40 40 is when I think you really change.
At least for me.
That's when I was like,
oh,
I'm going to die soon.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Really start to feel your mortality and things.
Do you have a sense of urgency to them?
Yeah,
I'm on the cusp of that.
I mean,
I remember,
I remember the 29 I remember getting a,
I dunno,
I remember feeling like,
wow,
this actually is Hoppen Lang that's happening.
But I then remember that when I officially hit 30 like when it was 30th birthday
day,
I was like,
this feels different.
They usually don't feel different.
You go through 24 25 26 years.
I know.
Same thing these last few years,
35 36 37 I'm like nothing.
But I do expect that.
I don't think I'll be affected much by turning 39 no,
but I think that when I had the big four,
I'll be like,
whoa.
It is half the point.
It's kind of,
you really are at the halfway mark.
Theoretically.
I mean,
if you're lucky,
if you're lucky.
So scary.
I do think about it.
Don't want to live super old.
No,
no.
What?
How old do you watch it and say that it's not about the number.
I don't want to live for a long time in poor health.
That's how I feel.
See a lot of old,
like older people that,
oh my God,
fuck Eh.
And you can't not have my faculties and you know what I mean?
Yeah.
It was a good thing is though,
standup comedians,
because we tend to use our minds,
they we can work for,
I mean look at Milton Berle.
How old is he?
We always hold either we die really young or very old.
Phyllis Diller like 96 and she was still performing at like 94 or something and
hopefully all of you that,
that our fans now will be fans when you're old.
So he'll come see us and we'll be like,
I really did shit my pants today.
And everyone be like,
that's funny
James.
Yeah,
Carlin stayed fresh.
He was 80 something 70 he died at 70 well he did a lot of throw gas that looked
older.
He looked much older,
but he did a lot of blow.
I think what we've been talking about is that you can't,
you can't party at 50 like you did in your twenties because I think that
accelerates the aging process pretty much.
The partying,
partying,
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Fuck
her old comedians and we fuck fucking Rickles.
He lived at night.
He was working and he was doing shows,
shows dude.
Even to Jerry Lewis.
Right.
Is he still alive?
No,
he's good.
He was,
you know,
talking shit all too.
He was old as fuck.
Yeah.
He's always for burns,
Bob red buttons,
all those guys.
It's your favorite.
You love those guys were all old as shit man.
Yeah,
so there you go.
No,
I know.
Maybe the maybe doing comedy,
like actually being around laughing and stuff helps too and just keeping your
mind sharp and performing and got to keep your sword sharp to 50 50 50 50 that's
a Jerry Lewis lived so long is that it's sharpening a sword over day.
That'd be great.
If he turned that awful interview into a conversation,
the best conversation,
then I'd start to really like him.
Yeah.
He was like,
you know,
I can control my Oregon.
Nobody I know now that's an interview.
Yeah.
God Damn Dude.
I know.
I think about that because my parents are on that.
I mean,
you know your dad too,
they're in that window right before it all falls apart.
It's falling.
Or in the last chapters.
So like I,
you get to enjoy them.
You know,
I do
for this last,
this last run.
Yeah.
This is your last hurrah.
However,
I feel like your mother will outlive us.
I feel like she's,
she's of those going to sneak under the radar.
Yeah.
She'll be here for me.
Like I diet.
I hope they stick around.
I love your folks.
Yeah,
I do too.
They're fun.
I feel like I need to try to see them more,
you know?
Hey,
I know,
you know.
Well,
they're coming out.
They're coming up for the birth of the kid and July.
Yup.
For a Carl's Jr.
Somebody said it to me the other day,
they're like,
what are you gonna name your son Carl's junior?
And I was like,
hey listen,
we're show.
Yeah.
Carl's Jr is great.
I think Domino's for this one,
the Carl's junior was supposed to be Ellis' name.
Yeah.
Domino's.
Oh,
I'm craving dominoes 24 seven with this one.
I just don't do it.
I don't eat it all the time.
What have you named him seriously?
First name dominoes with the apostrophe and middle name belonging to dominate
the middle name.
Thin crust.
Right.
It'd be kind of cool.
That's what we order extra cheese.
Extra pep,
canny Peb when you're preggers you're stopping preggers guy.
Oh No.
Oh yeah.
We got to get into this food.
Then we were going to talk about why don't we open the show in a fine show?
Shit.
Shit longer.
Chip Blanca.
There's a lot I want to get into.
All right.
Here we go.
Here.
He [inaudible] year ago.
Tommy up Tom.
All right.
Hi.
Oh my God.
I'm looking for a white lady.
Oh,
she's a cat.
Two and dominant and be willing to put me in a dress and beat the shit out of
me.
Okay.
Call me [inaudible] street.
Don't.
No,
it go
to your mom's house.
In keeping with the theme that we've observed is also a shirtless guy is also.
Sure.
Yeah.
See,
this is a thing now,
right now.
Right now.
Right now,
right?
No,
now going,
I suck.
Right?
I don't even know what I was observing.
I don't know what I was feeling.
I don't know of Fremont Street.
Are you being serious?
That's what he said.
Fremont isn't San Francisco.
I mean,
I can only assume,
but I'm not,
I don't know.
Can I please see that again?
Oh,
sure.
I'm so confused right now.
Oh my God.
Looking for a white lady,
his tattoo and in it and be willing to put me in a dress and beat the shit out
of me.
Call me.
And this is your three months street.
There you go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's got a lot going on so much.
It's like,
where do you begin with a click list on the doctor drew a check.
That's right.
I'm gonna call this one the city of Fremont Street.
Accurate name for the file.
So see a Fremont,
Jesus.
I mean in
Fremont.
Cc Jim.
And again,
you stupid white bitch
is what I'm looking for is a stupid care to white bitch that put me in a dress
and beat the shit out of me.
Call me
22 yeah,
like slut.
No.
Here's what I find interesting about again,
everything.
Almost like a bag.
Yeah.
Submissively I'm looking for this and,
but then he switches it and gets agro.
I agree.
I'm not sure what the tactic is here.
Is it to shame her or to woo her in with his submission?
I don't know because it kind of seems like to me that maybe the tactic is by
insulting the potential dominant person.
Oh,
we're aggressive.
He's going to antagonize her and then she's going to come with a fury and a
really tight dress.
Yeah.
You better wear this dress.
You fucking sissy.
Yeah.
Really beat the shit out of him.
I'm like,
yeah,
because usually you don't see,
I want to be submissive,
beat the shit out of me and then you bitch,
you stupid because they don't,
I didn't know that they could insult the dom that was protocol.
Maybe he just really wants his ass kicked.
I'm more intrigued with his hair.
Yes.
And that's why we're married.
Yeah.
I,
I'm more intrigued.
All the things going on visually,
I'm more intrigued with the selection of which teeth he chose to keep.
You know what I mean?
I also like the framing that he [inaudible] six feet above the head so you can
see the ceiling really clearly.
Now the sound was good.
Yeah.
He's got a newer phone.
Who's got an yeah.
Um,
but I'm just saying why keep the entire bottom row of teeth and then none of the
top
and the bottom is really gray and yellow
like you.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Like why keen to jump.
One to jump.
Yup.
But why preserve just those like you,
you can clearly you're capable of keeping some of them.
Why not try to keep all of them.
Yeah.
That's a really good question.
So really good.
How much for you to fulfill this man's desires,
Tom?
Oh my God.
Let's talk a dollar amount.
I mean mouth mouthwash.
Who's loud mouth.
Are you more into his?
I'll tell you.
I'll the other guys.
Yeah.
Only because this guy's mouth smells of booze too.
This one here soaked in booze.
It smells like a,
like a warm beer.
Yeah.
You don't think the other guy drinks?
Not like this guy.
This guy's been drinking all day.
Yeah.
That's pretty bad.
Now,
what do you think?
They're both pretty disgusted.
Pretty Ratchet,
but see,
I think the other guys are more disgusting human being overall.
Why do you say that now?
That's an interesting,
he's a grocer dude.
Yeah,
because this guy is clean,
like he's got a clean pair of jeans so you just didn't have any regard for his
teeth.
But I mean the other one is sunscreen.
No,
yeah,
no,
he's been outdoors for awhile about doors for 50,
60 years.
But he's,
the other guy is,
I mean,
I wouldn't be surprised if the other guy keeps,
you know,
toenail clippings and like she was on the floor and then walks on.
He's just,
he's really bright house.
He's a specialty.
Disgusting.
He's got more mental problems.
This guy is just a fun drunk.
Yeah.
This guy's parlor trick
highs,
Madison and salts ditch.
He hates himself and then he hates the person that he's asking.
The favor.
Just hates himself.
Yeah.
It's all projection.
That's hilarious.
A lot of people are probably going to see
the parallels between him asking for that favor.
And then,
uh,
the piss on me beat me guy.
You know,
there are many.
Yeah.
We've uncovered,
by the way,
this isn't your mom's house exclusive.
Yeah.
We introduced the bill,
the truck out and we're fucking pissed.
Let me try it out and see.
Shares applied only as fuck man.
I'm looking at the heart.
See The differences that this guy is definitely amped up on some
10 once the girl should.
Yeah.
But the other guy I feel like is maybe not into drugs,
you know,
we don't know.
He doesn't look good.
Nothing looks good for sure on any of the people that we are.
Show policy is.
If it looks good,
don't play it.
But yeah,
I mean this guy,
this guy is in overdrive asking for his favor.
The other guy is actually pretty chill about it.
While I was going to say,
here's a really creepy child.
Your mom's house has broken so many videos,
genres,
the boring video and really born so many stars.
The FARC videos,
the dad Boehner videos,
and now we're breaking the overly excitable sexual request videos.
It's just exciting when we come up with a new genre,
we break barriers.
Glass ceilings shatter on this show.
Yeah.
This guys hopped up on drugs.
The other guy,
you could see him,
the lighting was better.
The sound was again shirtless.
So he does meet the criteria is huge here.
It's really something.
And you have to have a shitty apartment background that you got to see.
Like a ceiling track.
Yes.
Like a cottage cheese ceiling.
I was surprised how a doctor drew
led with that on every analysis.
He's like,
let's see what's going on in this apartment.
I had never really been,
I would always be focused on what the day looks like or what he said.
But no,
Andrew look around.
It was like,
hmm.
Yeah.
Really the best Dick Whore.
Well,
with the guy with the breathing and the Cop d,
is that the word?
Um,
his closet was behind him and you could see how disheveled his,
oh,
that guy's really,
really crazy and really high.
Yeah.
He's really disorganized.
And mentally too.
Now who do you think's the most fucked up?
So the Cop d guy,
the piss on me,
beat me.
Now we've got Julian Fellowes teeth.
Uh,
here's the thing about piss on me.
Beat me guy is that he might just be super fucked up in the sense that he is
chemically fucked up with everything with drugs.
Oh,
it's drawing might be able to behave normally not high when he's sober.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a totally,
I mean it's like anybody could fall into that trap in the way.
In other words,
if you put me on drugs and alcohol and make a video,
it's not going to be sign,
be a good video,
but I might be able to keep it together sober.
You know,
you really think no,
I would just,
let me just hear what you,
let me get hit when we need you here for,
you're hearing your argument correctly.
You're saying that the piss on me beat me gay when sober is somehow sane.
Like he,
he could be like you or me.
Maybe not.
No,
not like you or me because he's not normal.
Right.
Okay.
And he's not in the circle of normal.
Oh,
what I'm saying,
we're seeing him only amped up on dust and so this is a real heightened version
of who he is.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a good word for it.
He is.
I am that,
you know,
uh,
also CLPD d guy,
he's also is fucking all his videos,
but I think his eyes are more clearly mentally ill and so like you would
register more like a,
a shooter,
like a fucking,
you know.
Well yeah cause he's,
I think the CLPD guy also has delusions.
Yeah.
No,
he's really sick.
He's really,
yeah,
but pace on the beat me
Guy Piss
on me,
beat me guy.
I feel like probably has a job cause some,
yeah.
And he's gainfully employed.
He's got keys to can tell him like I need you to get this done.
And he'd be like,
all right,
drop it off over here.
Yeah.
He would do it,
but fucking CLPD guys held and capable.
He'd be like,
well I was walking out,
I see what you're trying to do to me.
And he's super paranoid.
He's like,
I fucking set that shit all fire ass hole.
Right.
Okay.
Hyper paranoid now.
What about the right now?
Right now,
right now.
Right now.
Super Paranoid.
Fucked up guy.
I think he might be bipolar.
Yeah.
I'm gonna to go with or manic
depression,
the mood swing.
I think there might,
there might be an element of mania to that right now.
Right now.
Right now that none may not just be drugs because that feels like mental
illness.
Yeah,
that's mania.
Let sounds like me.
You know what?
All good questions for doctor drew.
Next time he gets in here,
he can,
um,
tell us the,
it's Matt Manic here.
How manic that is.
Now this guy,
which,
okay,
so now that we've gone through all of our Sickos Julian Fellowes teeth here,
I feel as though he might just genuinely be an old school,
hundred percent homegrown SF pervert.
Just a hardcore guy who just leads with his Dick and he's putting himself out
there.
Like he might be the most normal he might be.
Yeah.
Cause he seemed sober.
I would say that he's sober in that video.
He's keys kinky.
He's weird.
He's the guy who when he's waiting to pick up his coffee goes,
um,
put a little extra cream in that when everybody goes like,
come on man.
And then Lyle gets a little kick out of it.
And you're like,
he comes in here,
he says stuff like that,
you know,
like,
but he's not really,
he's,
he's a creeper.
He'll come in,
he'll get off of his bicycle and he'll be wearing like the tight bicycle shorts
and like the clicky clicky shoes or something.
And he'll come in and he'll be annoying and he'll be gross like you said.
Yeah.
But he's not mentally,
I don't think he's mentally ill.
I think he's just got a kink.
Yeah.
Well we'll see.
You know,
then again,
I feel that way about a lot of these guys.
Excuse me.
And then two or three videos deep and you're like,
oh,
there's a lot more.
Show you having a lot more shit happening.
Well,
I hope he finds his padded white slut
pretty soon.
Hope she beats the shit out of him.
He's so,
and another thing too is that he's got an extra chin,
like a lot of Chin meat and you think that you'd record from the top,
but he does it from the bottom.
Not flattering or
not flattering.
That's true.
No,
it's not very good.
Um,
yeah.
See it's not a good angle.
You're not,
you're not doing yourself any favors.
He's just a perv that is a,
yeah,
it's very hanky.
That second chin.
Um,
yeah,
it just reminds me of what,
um,
we're watched Turkey.
Andre the giant document.
Oh yeah.
And there's a,
the interview.
I've interviewed a bunch of people.
It's,
it's really good.
Yeah.
Really good documentary.
Always loved Andre the giant,
but knew nothing about him.
Um,
and uh,
Bill Simmons Company did this.
It's a really cool documentary.
It shows all of,
uh,
like his whole story where he started in,
France,
and,
and they,
they have this where the naked ladies dance,
like really in depth look at his upbringing and how this,
you know,
he was like a normal size kid,
which is,
you know,
you just don't picture him like that.
And then he had this,
a pituitary just kicked in around 15,
which sounds about right,
right?
Like adolescence.
You really turned into an actual verifiable giant.
And he has,
Oregon's kept growing because he refused medical treatment.
And what happens is everything gets bigger,
but your heart doesn't.
Oregon's are squishing.
And,
and the thing is they offered him a surgery after he was already enormous,
so it would have been fine because he was worried about,
oh well my whole career go away.
Yeah,
you're not going to shrink.
And,
uh,
so he just kept growing and it's sad.
It's very sad.
But,
um,
but to your point,
I believe you wanted to bring up his friend friend trying to find this.
Uh,
let me see this.
I had,
I had this photo,
um,
at your insistence,
actually you,
uh,
this man appeared on screen.
You Go,
we have to look at this guy to study him.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
here's the thing.
I am,
I am by no means a supermodel.
I don't think Tom claims to be a model.
We were not in show business for our looks.
Uh,
but I do know that when a camera is on me,
I try,
I try to look good.
Like even today,
I have makeup.
It's Sunday.
I'm pregnant.
I don't want to put on makeup.
I do because I know the Internet is watching.
And when you're on camera you should just try to clean up a little bit of what's
there.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Oh,
work with what God gave you a hygiene,
you know,
grooming,
basic grooming stuff.
That's all right.
Yeah.
A model.
And this is a bad look dude.
This here.
Yeah,
it's a lot of red is drinking,
right?
Yeah.
But it's just interesting.
Facial hair.
It's more let's start from,
yeah.
Okay.
Look,
I don't understand what's going on because it's what connects is down here air.
Then he shaves off the whole Chin but leaves a chin strap.
Just a little chin strap at the bottom.
Nothing underneath that they send out thins out the part between the top of the
mustache in the nose.
That's like pencil thin Pierre.
Yeah,
it is very odd.
It's a very,
uh,
cause I'll tell you as a guy with a beard and who observes beers with this guy
needs is first of all,
why don't dip it low here.
Okay.
See how he dips it low?
Yes.
Exposes more of this cheek fat here.
You want to cover that and then you see this here definitely cover because this
just looks like you're in a period piece.
There's no reason for this at all.
Exposed.
And then I would let this grow.
You want to just cover
some of this loose meat right here cause it's,
he's got to go at that neat cause.
Here's my highlighting the gullet.
The beard is meant to kind of conceal your imperfections,
which I'm all for.
I get it.
Now what his mistake was is that he tried to contour his face with the beard.
Sometimes guys with really huge faces too who have no,
no sense.
No Sim was at all of of a jaw line.
We'll make a fake job.
So they go like this where the job would be.
Then there's just a,
it's like somebody drew,
it's like a surgeon's about to perform and they draw like here's where I'm going
to make my incisions.
That's what they draw and they think that that's giving the illusion that you're
seeing a jaw line,
but it actually makes the face look thinner and weirder because all you're doing
is looking at the line.
Looks Fair.
Noticing that all of this,
you're,
you actually,
it looks worse.
It looks worse.
This is just,
this is just bad,
bad work on bad concept and bad execution as a beer kind of shore yourself.
What do you,
so what are you suggesting he should do?
Well,
he should,
first of all,
he should just um,
saying,
fill this out.
Don't tip this down.
No,
keep it.
What's the line that he should keep?
He should go like he should go from here.
Yeah.
Across here.
Fill this in.
Fill this in completely.
[inaudible] for those of you who are listening is this guys,
first of all,
he's got a very,
he's a white guy with a very red,
red,
red face and then he's got like a white beard like that.
Kenny Rogers White,
but it's a super short shortly crowd and beard.
This is,
and it's on since.
And He's got his entire chin cut out of the beer except for little chin strap
buckle like you're buckling and helmet on.
He left a little bit underneath it.
One of the more bizarre beards I've ever seen me til.
It's just doesn't make sense.
And he's American.
He's not like,
yeah,
no,
he's not choice.
Speaking of nationalities by the way,
but know all respect to to uh,
Andre and his friend here.
But you do need beard help.
Okay.
I was just trying to help and choices.
What do you think of my fashion's today?
Oh,
I,
I think you're,
you're out of your fucking mind here.
I think that you've officially gone over to my team of euro trash.
Yeah.
I don't know how it happened.
You and I kind of switched places here.
Uh,
I think if you were to land in Budapest today,
people would start speaking Hungarian deal.
Really?
Oh my God.
You could be related to me right now.
Like you can be legit,
one of my cousins,
but the only thing you need is some white jeans.
Yeah.
Cause that's,
you know,
you're still looking to American here,
but that is a wild jacket for those of you listening.
He's wearing a tie dye powder blue Adidas old school,
three stripe,
like zip up.
Right.
Which are my favorite,
but like my frames,
crazy blue patterns on it.
Crazy psychedelic.
Yeah.
It's,
it's
really out of your wheelhouse.
I don't know what possessed you to wear this,
like feeling inside?
I just feel like it was my birthday and um,
I'm Stella.
I'm getting my groove back.
Yeah,
sounds like that.
Oh,
it looks good on you.
I will say I'm very jealous.
I kind of wish I had one like that.
This is something that's totally in your wheelhouse with regard to Andre is that
he was purported to be an amazing farter.
I know.
I love this part about the documentary covered in the dock for people that,
that's so funny.
Oh,
Vince Mcmahon talking.
Yeah.
Well he would be talking if I gave him the volume.
All right,
go
Andre.
So enjoyed flatulence when he pascal said it was,
it was an event,
my kind of guy,
flatulence,
that was his trademark and he had a real knack for lifting his left leg.
I would seem go into the launch position and I'd say,
Oh my God,
Harry clubs,
you've never heard anything like it.
It sounded like,
you know,
like a deep roar kind of like thing.
It would rumble
the sound of,
of Andrea taken a fart.
Taking off.
Take it off.
They were loud.
Big Man.
Big Farm.
Yeah.
Get you in an elevator and couple of those long,
42nd forts.
The song like skim was slapping me go.
I remember every once in a while the charter plane,
but to see the pilots,
you know,
almost like somebody get smoke in their eyes.
I'm a direct the plane on reed.
You can't form like that.
And your pants were pilots will be
f.
Dot.
God never again.
Never on this plan again.
That's pretty cool.
Huh?
Big Man.
Big Fart.
That's what they should have called this documentary.
Yeah,
I know.
That's it.
No,
this was the tombstone.
Big Man.
Big floods.
Even bigger.
Yeah.
That would be a contest.
Andre versus a king ass rapper.
Well,
I think it's funny that what everybody remembers of a man's life.
His farts.
That's pretty impressive.
They're just saying,
you know,
it's one of the things they talked about his drinking too.
Remember that?
Yeah.
He's a real boozer said,
you know,
it got,
it got to a point of mythology about his drinking,
but the,
but a couple people were like,
well,
you know,
his standard,
like his evening out began with 24 beers,
24 and then like three bottles of wine and you would drink those.
Uh,
they,
uh,
Rob Reiner said,
you know,
I'm princess bride.
He's like,
what'd you drink is like God,
like four bottles of wine,
three bottles of Cognac.
And they're like,
are you,
are you drunk?
And he was like,
ready to go look,
what do you want to do?
And he would start in the morning of shooting,
which is pretty funny.
But to him,
you know,
a bottle of wine is like a glass of wine.
Oh,
I know is because he's a giant.
He's like enormous.
Yeah.
Hey know he must've showed up holding a beer and it looked like a look like one
of those mini,
oh my God.
Yeah.
His paws were just tremendous.
They showed a here like it's size 22 ring,
which I don't,
I don't,
I'm sure that's not even something that they had,
you know,
everything is custom made for him and uh,
like a regular guy put three fingers in,
they tend to ring and it makes me think,
what do you think the,
uh,
speaking of three fingers,
but do you think downstairs was like,
well,
I mean his finger itself had to be like a normal dog sausage.
Yeah,
he's crying.
He's just like tap,
tap,
tap in away in there.
What they said that he was really big with the ladies.
Everybody was curious about what kind of horse cock this guy had on him.
Well,
kind of makes me think though that if it's anything proportionate to him,
they would just damage most women.
It's more of a novelty thing.
I don't think you'd want that on a regular,
I mean at least personally,
it's kind of like giving birth to a kid all the time.
It was up to a seven,
four,
500 and everything on him was just so big.
How big was nuts?
That's more,
I think that's even funnier.
Like carry around those big ass giant balls.
What about that thrust power though?
No,
I don't think he could cause at towards the end.
Like his back was.
So what about in his prime?
You don't think you want that guy on top of you?
I'd be scared.
I think most people would be like,
you lay on your back,
you know it was cow girl the way have you had like just wait,
just waves of load that it would just take 25 seconds.
And he ah,
I'm curious about,
you know,
and this is one thing that the documentary did an address and I think we're all
upset about what,
where his dumps,
like we know about the hearts.
What about the dump though?
It had to be really insane.
Shit's must've been bananas.
Of course.
I can't believe that guy could shit on a normal toilet.
I'm imagining,
and that was the saddest part actually about this documentary is that he spent
most of his life on the road and it's years ago.
It was before like modern day accommodation.
I mean,
I had a lot of empathy as I know you did for his travel burdens,
travel,
Burns,
and then um,
getting on airplanes and having to take up too regular economy seats and then
not being able to urinate.
Like he'd go to Japan from the states can fit in the laboratory and he couldn't
be swayed to like pee in a bucket and then put the bucket in the toilet and they
would just pull the curtain piss in a bucket.
So sad and dumped a bucket and then beds and cars and just must've been
horrible.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
fascinating documentary.
Very well done.
Really,
really good.
I really enjoyed that.
Um,
and I do this real quick.
I want to give this shout out because nothing is more exciting than free stuff.
And I came home from this last week in Atlanta too.
So much free stuff.
It's always just,
I mean,
I feel very lucky to get it,
but I just wanted to,
I got tons of stuff from roots of fight,
all those t shirts,
sweatshirts,
all that fight stuff.
Yes.
That was awesome.
Oh,
I remember I had to model it for me.
It was great.
Uh,
the undefeated sent me shoes and hats.
Thank you for that.
Um,
I forget the guy's name.
Is it Jesse?
I don't know his name,
but um,
the team and undefeated if you know anyone there.
Thank you guys for sending that.
I got coffee from smoking aces in Lexington and somebody who was at my show,
I spoke to him for a minute during the show,
sent me coffee.
We've got a big day from biobee day,
which is getting installed Monday.
I am so excited for this big day.
Yeah.
So I don't have a review yet because we haven't used it,
but it's,
it's getting installed.
And then I also wanted to shout out to,
um,
cause I remember if I,
you know,
with,
with this schedule,
with the movie,
it really fucked up when I remember if I said something and everything's like
out of order.
Um,
but I did rogue and the other day if you want to see that I was on a Joe's
podcast.
I did cold bear a few weeks ago.
If I don't know if I mentioned it on this,
on this show or not.
Did I tell the Jared subway story?
So it's a,
it's funny if you want to check it out loud,
people ask me,
do you guys talk about politics because I don't want to watch it.
And I'm like,
no.
So there's no politics.
Um,
you can just watch it if you want.
And I did.
Jesus and Miro,
um,
the viceland show,
if you want to watch that,
I'm on an episode of that too.
So I'm just plugging those things because they were all fun to do a lot of
publicity for your special,
a lot of publicity for the special.
Yeah.
It's wonderful.
Most importantly,
and I don't know if you're ready to bring it up,
but I'm so excited.
I'm so chomping at the bit
to start talking about this cause we,
we sat around yesterday.
Yeah.
And I've been thinking about it ever since.
Okay.
I mean,
are you ready?
Okay.
Well we were talking about,
we,
we had some friends come over and we thought,
why don't we get like some donuts for them?
Yeah,
that's right.
And the friend goes,
you know what,
actually we're not going to eat them or pretty health conscious.
And we're like,
yeah,
we are too.
We just thought it would be funny.
We haven't had donuts in forever.
Yeah.
And then we got to thinking like,
what's your favorite doughnuts?
What's your favorites?
If you're going to do a doughnut run,
what would you get?
Personally,
I'm a cake all the way.
Yeah.
I hate 'em.
I don't know what the other one is called.
The batter or something.
I don't like that squishy.
I don't like shit with Jelly.
Very light.
It's a lighter cake is heavier,
like heavy.
And I like some chocolate frosting.
I like my sprinkles on there.
Yeah.
But,
um,
fuck anything with like a jelly filling.
I fucking hate that.
Like,
uh,
I don't like those.
Um,
what else do we hate?
What else do you hate?
A,
yeah,
I'm not into the jellies and jams and it's gross.
I bear claws.
I can tolerate for like two bites and then I'm really old branch coolers.
Oh,
is that,
oh,
the chocolate topping whiskeys circled one.
Yeah.
I like those.
Those are good.
Um,
uh,
I mean a regular old fashioned glaze
I love and all cash and glaze can do that.
I like those.
I used to say,
let me get a dozen classics.
Classics.
Yeah.
Um,
I do however,
enjoy a Krispy Kreme in.
I know that's not a cake doughnut.
If it's fresh and hot.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
I do like the donut holes.
Here's what happened.
And when I like it,
everything donut with all the disgusting crumbs.
The ones that you get at.
Um,
I know I'm not a Dunkin donuts person,
but I do like that they're everything.
Donate
the crumbs.
Having the,
what's your favorite one would if you're making it.
Yes.
And then from there it went to how many of those things you could eat?
In other words,
if,
if you go like a crispy creme,
fresh hot one.
Yeah.
How many could you handle?
Both.
And then we talked about how many you could eat before you felt sick,
you know.
Well,
the Krispy Kreme,
I think before you feel sick is one,
let's be honest.
Like you eat it,
it tastes good.
And then I'm already like such a sugar rush.
It's so much.
It's overwhelming and it's good.
But Krispy Kreme,
realistically,
I could eat maybe three before I want it.
Before I vomited.
You think so?
I think you would vomit after three any more than three.
And I would,
I would feel so sick.
I definitely can't do it pregnant.
Um,
but
how about you?
I don't know.
I mean,
I definitely,
I've never done more than one or two of those hot Krispy Kreme ones.
You know,
you never don't more.
Number two,
I've never bought them.
In other words,
I've only had them when I am in an office.
I've never,
I've never actually stopped in and purchase.
Oh yeah,
I know,
right?
Never.
I've had doughnut holes.
Those are not from there.
From like a Dunkin donuts or something.
Again,
I liked the cake version.
I don't hate the mushy,
whatever the fuck that is.
So I wonder,
but how many could I max out on
the donut holes?
I'm wondering that one right now.
So here's,
here's,
wait.
Yeah,
I think the chocolate doughnut holes are usually,
I feel like those are cake like we're talking about.
And then that the,
that the glazed ones might be no,
it's how old fashion it could be either.
Or you can get them old fashioned homes.
Okay.
So anyway,
what's your favorite let,
let's start there.
Like what is,
what's the donut that you can eat the most of?
It might be just chocolate,
like chocolate,
chocolate.
In other words,
the chocolate cake style was,
yeah,
you could do more than a few of those.
Like that's what you want to eat multiples up.
So what I'm saying?
I think so.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
with that stuff,
I don't want something crazy.
I just want,
you know,
I like powdered donut to like an old pattern.
The Gel,
the gel or no,
no jelly.
No,
no,
no.
Wait,
I hate those.
And they're all squishy.
And then the powder,
it gets all over your face and your mouth and your beard.
Yeah,
those,
so which one?
Okay.
So here's the thing.
Now if you're going to do a challenge,
which I think,
I feel like I should challenge,
this is where it's happening.
Someone to do it though,
right?
I don't know.
Sitting alone and doing it,
they think it's better to have competition.
Well who are you thinking?
I mean obviously we know a really fat guys.
Are you serious?
Well,
I mean he's fat and
I'm sure there's a challenge.
Should we try to call him?
Let me see if
there's no way he wouldn't do this.
But wait,
before you call him,
we need to determine what type of donut this will be cause.
Cause here's our thinking.
Okay.
We were talking about this yesterday.
There's the regular cake donut,
let's say chocolate with chocolate frosting versus the donut hole.
Now a lot of people will be like,
oh clearly it's harder to eat the whole doughnut with the frosting.
I could eat,
you know,
more of the whole,
I saw many more holes.
The hole is the way to go because it's more fun.
You know,
you,
you get a bunch you can look down and I I on,
I don't think you can eat as many as you think.
Well that's a good part about it too.
Especially Mr. Exactly.
Yes.
So let's see.
I think you're going to get really sick quickly on those whole cause the sugar
on those.
Ah,
Shit.
He's not answering his fucking full.
What?
We'll set it up.
I think the sugar content on a on a whole is it's a lot,
cause I can only eat like two or three of those before I start to feel kind of
time.
I think it's deceptive and I think,
I mean he's flying because it goes straight to my son though.
He's fine.
Yeah.
Shit.
Okay.
So,
so let's,
let's talk about your number then versus what you think he's going to say.
I think so.
We're trying to Max out here.
Right?
And you're trying to map in a timeframe to,
it's got to be within a time.
Can you tell me what are you comfortable with?
Here's a,
here's the deal.
We're going to set up the parameters with Bert.
Yeah.
So that we,
we set up the game.
How many,
I think,
I'm trying to think like eating cat because I also don't want to do like a in a
minute or something,
you know?
Oh,
that sucks.
Here's the thing.
I don't want to see,
I don't want the hot dog eating the Nathan's thing where you're cramming and
it's a quick,
you know what I'm saying?
It doesn't have to be that.
It can be like in a leisurely enough of a pace.
I'm talking,
I want to see volume.
I want to see,
I want to see quantity.
How about,
um,
12 minutes.
12 sounds good.
Uh,
down at,
uh,
yeah,
two three.
There you go.
That's funny.
Yeah.
12 minutes.
Okay.
How many a minute?
Let's see.
Casually.
Um,
he's not going to be casual.
No,
he's not.
He's going to go up.
But that's the thing.
It's almost like which strategy do you want to use,
right?
I mean,
do you think we could do 40 in 12 minutes?
Oh my God.
That's so many of you think sec,
dude.
I think past 10,
you're gonna of Barf.
Oh 10 is nothing.
Come on.
Here's the thing.
I think after two dozen I would feel pretty sick.
And then it's how much further can you push it?
Past sickness.
Yeah.
So I mean after 24 be like,
oof,
that's a lot.
Feel pretty gross.
It's a lot of sugar.
It's like cake.
Yeah.
And then like so much.
And your stomach.
Yeah.
And I'm going to vomit.
Yeah,
you're going to be sick.
You're going to want to anyways.
Yeah.
You can't digest all that Shit,
right?
[inaudible] what's your dump going to be like after all that?
Sugar.
That's just a crazy sugar.
Sugar Binge.
Should I go for 40 that's so crazy,
Tommy.
No 20 no,
that's so easy.
That's not even a challenge.
20 of those is disgusting,
but it's not a challenge though.
I'm saying I could just fly through.
I know I could.
Are you going to train for this?
No.
Just show up.
Let's say for,
I'll say 40 okay.
And then what do you think he's going to say?
Definitely if I say 40 he's going to go.
Yeah.
But I think,
well let's let him say his number first or,
well,
we already said it,
so he's like this tall people are going to tag them on it for sure.
I think if I think I would challenge him,
I would be like,
do you think you can do 80 I'll,
I'll just start with that just to see if he's like course metallurgy it easy.
We'll do a hundred now.
He does have a high tolerance for sugar because of his alcoholism.
He also has a high tolerance for indulgence.
Yeah.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Just for like taking it in.
So yeah,
he does.
He he gorgeous a lot.
Yeah.
But that's the thing is even the 40 thing,
that's not really that crazy of a number.
It's almost like I'm,
I'm predicting it based on how sick I want it feel,
because in truth I could,
I could,
I could eat more,
but I already,
I'm already picturing how sick I'm going to feel doing this and I really just
want him to see him even more.
Like that's,
that's the goal.
So maybe we just make your number lowers that.
He no higher.
He's going to,
he's going to try it out to you.
Yeah.
Now here's the other question.
Do we go store bought Entenmann's Ah,
no,
we go a fresh donut.
How's does,
do we go gas station?
No,
those packs with like the chocolate,
the sediment.
The fake ass powders are not cool.
No.
So where do we get the donuts?
It's got to be a little bit of a shock.
Donut shop.
Yeah.
We'll talk to them.
We'll set up like,
we're going to buy this many no fucking way.
My Mommy's to get those shitty ass Entenmann's uh,
the,
the powder ones with the red jelly in the middle or the hostess.
She was so fucking nasty dude.
It's,
by the way,
somebody,
I'm noticed they were watching it back episodes and when our son was baptized,
it's episode three 53 mom's house.
Um,
you're talking about how your dad couldn't make it.
Yes.
And he went overseas.
Where'd he go?
Do you remember?
She was at Vietnam.
Yes.
And made a prediction and they pulled it.
Stop it.
Yeah.
So you know,
we had,
we had a great time.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was going to,
our son's going to heaven now and hopefully we'll have a cool pictures from
Vietnam too.
Maybe I'll have a new mom.
I don't know.
I forgot to check this.
Just
did your new mom.
Wow.
My Vietnam.
If you,
wow.
Isn't that interesting?
I knew back then.
Yeah.
What a neat story.
Maybe this is when the love connection began.
Who Knew?
I mean it was an interesting choice that my father chose to go to Vietnam over
attending his only grandchild's baptism.
That in and of itself was a fun thing to do.
Deal with blank.
He's amazed.
Yeah,
there you go.
Well,
I wonder how many have,
yeah,
that was amazed.
How many half Vietnamese brothers and sisters I have.
What do you thought Alastair found it?
Thank you Alistair.
How many?
Oh,
how many siblings do you think I have worldwide is the real question.
There's no way it's done.
There's no way.
It's none.
I know.
I mean he's been straight bang in since 1980 I would say like hardcore dropping
seeds in bitches internationally and like your dad,
he is not of the generation that's like responsible for,
you know what I mean?
No,
I talk about it on stage,
how
I didn't,
I mean my dad told me that he didn't,
he's never ever pull it out.
It's crazy.
Like jump and clips and people always just did it and he was like,
yeah.
I'm like,
how did you know that you wouldn't get pregnant?
He was like,
oh look.
They would say we don't care.
I'm like,
yeah,
but in your dad's doing it around the world
international clip dumps for a long,
since 1980 dude,
most of his adult life has been spent just Pam,
Pam,
third world countries or I'll be your mouth open your mouth.
There is no way.
I bet you man.
I'll bet she when he kicks it,
I'm going to have people coming out of the woodwork like I'm your half brother.
I'll be like,
you fucking do look like me.
Like a half Vietnamese brothers sister.
That'd be crazy.
Well be nice to have siblings.
I mean,
I am an only child.
I welcome,
I welcome you,
my international sibling's wherever you guys are.
Thailand also,
he visits
the Philippines,
places like that.
Can I have siblings?
They're all kinds of stuff happened in there.
Um,
it's so crazy.
I can't believe it that we predicted.
I predicted this Vn your mommy's little question that's been bugging me for a
few days.
I thought the two of you were the only ones who could help.
If your arm was caught off at the shoulder,
would you still need to wear
deodorant?
Furthermore,
would you for appearances sake,
shaved the lack of armpit hair or just rock the hairy shoulder mount?
Thanks,
Jeanne.
Brett p s piss on me.
Beat me.
Yup.
Yup,
Hmm.
Well,
I think if you are cut off at the shoulder,
you don't have to wear deodorant because there's no pitch.
No pit.
Yeah.
There's no nothing covered.
Like there's,
yeah,
there's no sweat.
Yeah.
It's just open air.
It's like putting deodorant on
back or something.
You know,
I was watching Britain's,
it was,
what's it called?
Shut-Ins bread.
Britain's fattest people.
Yeah.
And it's only where the folds of fat are that these people would kind of take a
wet rag and wash between the places you want to deodorize the places that are
mashed together.
Sure.
So yes,
I think they are pretty big,
right?
Yeah.
Trauma.
I mean that's all in stones.
You lay 28 stone.
I'm like,
I don't know what that shit is.
I had to look it up,
but I'm a pretty massive people that that's a good one.
Britain's Britain's um,
vast,
yeah.
Written off people.
Yeah.
It's not a cold burns fat as people.
It's called like shut-ins.
Right?
Uh,
Britain's,
yeah.
Fantast
here's another email at mommy's and writing this while the scene in episode four
42,
you're debating the cleanliness of the soap bar in the ass.
Sure.
You are assuming that nothing can live on the soap bar,
but I have a grade eight science fair,
a gold medal that says otherwise owe her my experiment.
I had subjects place their hands on petri dishes,
then wash their hands with a used bar of soap,
then place their hands on another petri dish after incubating the dishes.
At my dad's lab,
it was shown that the post wash dishes contained more bacteria then the prewash
dishes,
thus demonstrating that bacteria thrives on soap bars.
Shit,
you're running the bar across your ass.
There's shit bacteria on that bar.
Hold.
Hope that helps.
I got to run.
I had a homeless black thug coming over to fuck me in the ass regards.
Chris.
This helps.
I love that.
That's a helpful email.
Thank you,
Chris.
Really helpful.
Thank you very much for that.
Um,
so yeah,
that is a,
here is,
where is it?
Nope,
I don't have it here.
Fuck.
Oh,
here it is.
Um,
not going to stop me.
My,
I read a tweet that I had come in.
Yeah.
I was just going to say that with regard to that message.
I definitely won't stop doing that.
No,
neither will lie.
And I believe it builds a resilience,
a tolerance to these types of bacteria.
It's fine.
You and I have not gotten sick so far.
Uh,
you gotta you gotta live your life.
I can't,
I can't be worrying about every fucking germ.
True.
What I mean true.
Now Tom,
and this one's for you.
You're not going to like this.
But,
um,
in light of our open defecation conversation a while back,
the tweets have been pouring in.
The emails have been pouring.
I know him.
I know what you're about to say.
Well,
let me read a tweet.
Okay,
let me quote the listeners on this one are very fired up at you.
This one comes in from CJ foster.
He says,
Whoa,
hold on.
Christina P and Thompson.
Sigora Tom said he never opened desiccated.
What about the poo pile and his friends that he,
him and his friends had hashtag serious news.
Uh,
yeah,
CJ,
thank you.
And the many others,
the tweets,
the port and the emails.
Tom,
I'm going to ask you on behalf of all the mommies watching and listening,
what about the poo pile?
Yeah,
it's a great question,
but it's um,
it's very easy.
The case,
um,
I saw it said open defecation.
Open defecation is a song called open defecation.
I didn't realize that.
Open defecation,
open defecation my ladies dissertation was on.
Yeah,
that's cool.
Yeah.
And in fact,
many households in rural India don't prioritize having a latrine.
So that's conveyor India to some other countries in the world.
On the vertical axis,
at this graph we have the rate of open deprecation.
So I have a deaf,
a CACHACA.
Yeah.
I'm curious about the song.
So here's the answer to people questioning open defecation versus the poop pile.
Okay.
Uh,
the poop pile is a backyard.
And while that's outside,
no,
I just didn't consider open defecation.
What she's talking about is people,
the way I interpreted it,
it's like walking down the street,
finding just a,
a place that is not designated for it and doing it.
We had x marks,
the spot,
a ladder,
a group,
people watching,
everybody's doing it.
So it wasn't like,
it wasn't the same as saying like,
Oh yeah,
I just,
I had to go and I was a,
I was in front of a business.
I just dropped trout and I took it.
That's why.
So you're,
you're saying your interpretation was that as long as there is a designated
location for somewhere to Poop,
it's,
it's not considered open.
I mean it was a dead,
first of all,
it's an enclosed backyard with a fence.
Trees.
Um,
you know,
I just didn't think of that as as open defecation.
Yeah.
Right.
An NC NCI interpreted as many of our listeners did.
Um,
open and outside.
Outside will our rather in an place other than a toilet.
Yeah.
No.
And I can see place designated for pooing.
I can see how there's not many places you should pool.
The toilet is the only place
Lester is a poo pile mark for you to pour it.
And that's exactly what we did.
And I'm going to see
my to poop pile comrades this weekend.
Actually I would like some kind of a testimony.
Maybe a lie detectors situation.
Yeah,
I'm serious.
I'm so sick of not knowing the truth behind this.
Ruth is here.
I'm telling you the truth.
No,
I want a lie detector test about this fucking poop pile and I think the
listeners deserve it.
We can do it.
Great donut challenge.
And then after that lie detector test.
Okay.
Might Affect your test.
Why not?
Is anyone out there a lie detector person?
We'll find somebody.
Oh,
look how nervous you look already.
I see the fear in your eyes.
Fear in my eyes.
I was one of the founders of the poop pile when the,
probably the best pool or in the whole group.
Yet when the subjective pooping outside came up,
it didn't even trigger a memory inside of you because it was designated as the
place to go,
but an outdoor place to go.
Theoretically,
it's an outdoor place to go,
but it's not.
I mean,
I'm talking about people shitting on the side of the road,
shooting into the ponds,
shitting,
you know,
like go into the lake at the park and taking a shit there.
That's what I interpret.
This was like,
Hey,
let's all do this together.
Let's bond as friends.
It's friends and family.
Walk me through this again at the poop pile that there is a ladder and then you
mean to tell me that you hang your,
your ass off the top of the ladder.
You're sitting down on top of a ladder.
It's like a makeshift ladder on a tree.
Okay.
Again,
this makes this,
I don't know if this is the same story Lesnar's you guys are the experts.
I'd go ahead and compare stories or past shifts like hoards nailed into a tree
so that you can clients,
you know what I mean?
Like,
okay,
I'm listening.
He dried diagram.
I mean I can't,
I could draw,
you can go ahead.
There's a let's,
let's try to make this lie happen.
Go ahead.
Sure.
Yana Brown lock here.
And in fact that's how I spent two weeks of law school and go ahead.
So
I'm trying to,
it makes no sense to me.
Makes a ton of sense that a group of guys at first of all the stench must have
been overwhelming.
There's no way you want to shit on top of your friends shit.
And this is so stupid and silly and so disgusting.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's see the physics of this.
All right.
I'm trying to do,
what time of year did the poop pile take place?
That would be a late spring,
early summer.
Oh,
so it's nice and hot.
And this is in the south North Carolina.
Yeah.
So you mean to tell me and the humid a southern boy,
a ball.
Me Summer night.
Summer Day.
You guys were taking turns shitting on a pile of pill.
That's what you're trying to tell me this in proximity to your living space
right there.
Right there.
So you guys probably had windows open to for summer breezes and such,
and you didn't mind the stench of a poop pile coming into your room.
You didn't bother you guys to be next to a sewage dump.
Uh,
Tom,
is that what you're telling me?
And you had girls coming over and looking at your pile of shit.
Oh,
bullshit.
Yeah.
I like to talk to one of those girls.
If you could produce said girl,
if there's a woman out there that saw the poop pile,
let me know.
Okay.
All right,
well that's something else.
Here is what would happen.
Yeah.
Here's like a big tree.
Okay.
And then nailed into the tree are pieces of wood that would act as a ladder in
other words.
Sure,
sure.
You know what I mean?
You could call it like a child would use for a tree house.
Yeah.
Okay,
so you climb up this tree and then on this huge branch here,
and then we had like a toilet seat out here.
Oh,
that's a new addition to your story.
Well,
you know,
it's like it's,
it's a makeshift,
totally annuity and then you hold onto this so you don't fall.
What's that?
What is this that you're talking about?
What are you holding onto?
It's like a metal bar that we nailed into the treaty.
Nail the Ma.
I didn't do it.
It must be Casey.
Okay.
And then,
and then you just pooped,
threw it into the poop pile there,
right?
This is the thing.
I was born yesterday.
No,
I'm serious.
This is,
this is Loney.
No,
it's not blown.
It really isn't Poo Baloney.
We did this for a while and a lot of people pooped off of,
this is so dumb.
You don't understand the Carolinas.
No,
I understand.
A bunch of 20 year old guys and their primary motivation is to get laid not to
shit on top of each other.
Shit.
Hmm.
You really think this was going to help you get laid in college.
You weren't thinking like that.
We're thinking more like bonding with our neighborhood,
the group experience.
And your neighbors didn't mind the smell of human who wafting,
right.
Summer nights primitive.
We were,
we were all into it.
Yana you're the main thing is that when you would call out that you're going to
do it.
So many people that run who,
who would run towards this neighborhood,
kids and other adults or the lion.
No,
I'm serious.
The lie is that,
let's see what this song is.
I don't remember this one.
Okay.
That's the case.
It's like equine diarrhea.
Diarrhea is quite diarrhea,
diarrhea decline.
I've seen the guy shouldn't Nally sorry guys.
Shit.
Downtown.
Anytime you have the urge to shit,
you would just drop trout
as DJ show reference with the variation.
Really good.
But yeah,
no,
the poop pile is definitely real.
And um,
I understand why people were questioning.
And the more you tell the story,
the more senseless it becomes and the less sense it makes.
And the more detail that you,
the more webs of lies they go into the poop pile.
It's,
it's utter nonsense.
This is nonsense.
I Dunno.
Anything you're talking about right now,
but it's complete lies.
Okay.
You're out of your fucking mind with this stuff.
I'm not,
I'm really not.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm really trying to help you.
Okay.
Um,
what do I want to scanning?
Oh,
speaking a scatting.
Yeah.
Everyone was really,
really into scatting and it's,
it's so cool.
And
we look at the people go crazy for them doing this too.
[inaudible]
no doubt.
No
doubt.
Ooh,
my favorite now these are two very talented individual Ella Fitzgerald for me.
Yeah.
She really is super talented people and there,
this is annoying the shit out of me.
Terrible.
Yeah.
I could listen to Ella Fitzgerald singing all day,
but yeah,
this is fucking nonsense
hoodie.
I like.
Yeah,
but like the people sitting next to that because like your cousin Brian in the
front,
your cousin Brian would love something like this is my face right here.
Yes.
Fuck.
Are they doing,
do you know what I'm saying?
This is the same audience member who thinks that like,
um,
remember that movie that came out a while ago that was silent?
Yeah.
Years ago.
They made a silent movie and this is the person on the academy that votes for
things like that.
Like,
oh,
what a treasure,
what an artistic treasure.
This crap.
Yeah.
Tom,
let's do our duet like they're doing where he answers and ready.
Yeah.
Bobo.
Bobo,
Bup,
bup,
bup.
Sam [inaudible].
Wow.
Wow,
wow,
wow biome.
We did it.
That was great.
We should be hosting whenever a piece of shit.
That thing was,
well,
maybe we could get better at it.
I'm not sure if we can loud from singer sacred and today's video is for all of
my jazz singers out there.
Oh Shit.
I'm just be looking at sketching.
Even if you don't sing jazz and you've never scouted before,
you will still get a lot out of this video.
Okay.
Pause.
In order to stack,
you actually have to have a few Ninja music things going on in order to get it
going.
We still did that benefit your entire thinking vibe.
Anyway,
so what is Scott?
Well,
if you've never heard of scat before,
it sounds like a base.
Oh No,
don't do it.
Please.
[inaudible]
that kind of using nonsense syllables to basically turn your voice into an
instrument because there's no instruments around or you don't have the ability
to play them.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's tremendous.
Very similar to the way that a whole one would be up on stage sort of saxophone
or a trumpet.
It's not.
No,
of course not.
It doesn't sound,
it just sounds like it.
Like you said,
a two year old playing pretend.
Yeah,
it's annoying.
We should nominate our son for a grantee
pop.
This is what infants do on their crib at night before they fall asleep.
When they wake up,
they kind of babbled to themselves.
It's the same shit is so fucking retarded.
I mean,
this is,
uh,
another,
check this out.
Each contestant will have to Scott for as long as possible without taking a
breath.
Oh No.
I have scattered professionally.
Um,
and I'm pretty well known for my scap style boots.
Ski in the Midwest and welcome to the big leagues sweetheart.
Sick Dude,
dude,
dude.
She's off to a very controlled the notes that you need a commentator,
he showed you millions of die.
Scott fans back in the Midwest.
Roofing.
Sonia on right about now.
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee,
and she's not disappointing.
Dave Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee,
outstanding Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Bring it home.
Girlfriends,
girlfriends out thought.
Ah,
and there you have it.
Where districts checkers.
Yeah,
Sonia seems quite disappointed.
I would have a little distracted by the band.
I really wanted to grow with them and then before I know it ahead,
I had to hold my guys staring at you.
Jump Out,
jump out the hole with the scad,
but it was cool.
Next up is Terry who needs to be 36 seconds for the title.
Oh that,
that that though I'm not quite sure exactly what style terrorist going with the
style and everyone really even qualify as a star on the toe,
but you definitely can't question that young man's heart and back and back and
back.
He's hot.
It was this like this is a gag video actually.
Oh right.
Cause must be,
well I thought the lady before him actually,
she seemed sincere really was like,
yeah,
doing it at this.
This is clearly over the
[inaudible] pop,
pop,
pop nonsense.
It's the worst.
Um,
we'll be working on a scat album for those of you guys that are interested in a
quick how many,
we're just going to do scat from now on.
Yeah.
There's such a demand.
Um,
Jeez.
Let's see what this,
I want it to read another email that came in our tweet rather.
Yeah.
Last time we were asking how is it
that tattoo artists learn how to Tattoo?
Yeah.
That was cool.
This came in from lefthanded Morty on Twitter and he writes,
Hey,
tattoo artist's practice on pig skin before they ever tattoo a person.
Pig Skin is very similar to human skin and if you wrap it around a mannequin
body part,
it is a great training tool for aspiring tattoo artists.
Um,
that,
so that makes a lot of sense.
Now that makes sense,
doesn't it?
That's pretty cool.
Very interesting.
Speaking of a Schema do bat.
Oh,
cool.
Things a little quick.
Quick Stop off in studio g here.
Oh,
shut up real quick one.
You're kidding.
Wait a minute.
Have I not been up on him?
You're listen.
Oh Fudge.
The dream still lives and my dream is for us to love one another.
All of us.
Oh,
that's right.
Sorry.
I did see this is so ridiculous,
right.
It's really reminiscent of,
I like that.
Yeah,
I really liked that.
Yeah.
He's so,
he's so phony.
It's just reads so false.
It doesn't,
it
uh,
his beard needs well,
yes.
I was going to say that.
Yeah.
Let's see it.
Do you love one another?
All of us.
Oh my gosh.
I bet he's just insufferable.
Yeah.
I remember when,
um,
he was like,
he was interrupted doing studio g for his birthday and he was like,
is this supposed to happen?
It's going on here.
Yeah.
He,
he wasn't that night.
Was that?
Yeah.
All of us.
Ah,
he's creepy.
Super Creep.
He needs beard help.
Definitely.
He needs to grow it out a lot more than the other guys should get together.
Go over their beards.
Definitely.
Yeah.
That's good.
What is this right here?
This old lady polluting her street by parking.
Oh,
this is like an old lady losing her shit.
You want to see it?
Yup.
Okay.
What
Shit are you literally uh,
it's none of your business.
God Damn phone.
No Man.
Get off your goddamn phone.
Are you my mom?
Mommy,
Mommy.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Where's you'll back to Africa?
We have wrong.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
She's got a croquet.
She's real crazy.
Yeah.
She got a buzz cut.
You see that?
She does that.
We're really clear
cut.
Yeah.
She,
she's only missing that guy's beard cause she has his haircut.
The,
yeah,
that's a lead with that.
She just was like,
God,
here go to Africa.
Doesn't matter.
This is public.
This is public property.
This belongs to this.
See,
this is what Hans did.
A city.
You'll get the fuck outta here.
Get outta here.
Go back into your house.
I like him.
I also liked to get the shit out of here is not an expression.
It's fuck.
And he corrected her was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Well,
Becky through a house check your goddamn house.
No,
no.
I like,
I like fucking this specific spot.
Me Too.
He is right though.
And I hate when people think that the front of their house belong to them.
It doesn't belong to the city.
If you're on the street,
you're on the street.
Yeah,
Dude.
I know one likes for the record.
No one likes cars parked in front of their house.
Same Way.
But you're allowed to of course it's public property.
Yeah.
Stupid.
I almost liked it.
Um,
it seems like her level of anger doesn't match her face entirely.
Oh.
Like she was kind of flat.
Like the expression is kind of strange.
She was like,
get Outta here now,
but she's not.
You know what I mean?
Like it's just like start reading in her eyes.
It's interesting.
Shit.
Too much botox.
What did I do to you?
Shut up.
Nobody's threatening you.
I'm polluting your sweet.
You should just go back into your house,
polluting your street.
Since when did the street belonged to you?
Yeah.
She's a real quick get the hell Nah.
If I were this guy,
I might come back and park here every day for this show.
God Damn,
she's real fired up.
I'll go,
fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
You done.
You think she's just old and crazy?
Yeah,
she's angry.
She's just full of rage.
She flipped out actually at first,
just the anger started with who was parked in front of my house.
Yeah.
And then she had to take it up a notch.
Cut.
She's really angry though.
Hell,
you think she is
80 something?
I was going to think like 47 48 now she's way up.
She's not doing so hot gene and of her road.
Yeah.
It was the end of a road.
MMM.
Somebody pointed out that,
that they think that um,
oh my God,
I have a hilarious clip.
Tell me if you think this is hilarious or not.
Ready.
Here we go.
This is pretty good.
[inaudible]
oh no,
no,
no.
I don't like this.
I don't like it.
Oh my God,
Babe.
What part is funny?
This screen was funny.
You don't think it was funny?
Did he crash his legs jumping off that thing?
I don't know.
You don't get to see it.
He just,
he didn't jump from that high.
So the cars,
the people listening,
there's a car on a tow truck like on the upward,
like a double decker and it starts to roll off and the guy jumps together.
He just jumps one that's not that fun.
I mean it's higher than you want to jump screaming.
He hurt his leg.
[inaudible]
no,
he hurt his leg name.
That's funny.
No.
Why not?
Cause I feel bad for him.
He hurt his leg.
I think it's not,
it's not okay.
Poor guy.
Okay.
It's too,
it's too sad.
I feel so really it's a hard job.
He already has.
I know that so bad for him.
A lot of stuff.
Yeah.
So these guys are jumping out of a plane check.
[inaudible]
pretty crazy.
This guy,
I don't know.
Yes.
Like improvise better.
Do something.
I don't know why his parish parachutes open,
but something happens.
Why are you laughing?
I don't know why you're laughing.
That's like my worst nightmare.
Oh God.
Okay.
Ha.
Yeah.
And then when he cries,
does that make you laugh?
What grown poor man in the military.
Ah.
I can't believe you don't find those so mentally disturbed.
You got to bring this to your therapist.
Oh,
how do you not find that funny.
Gotcha.
Lamp.
A baby.
I got it.
I feel really bad for that guy.
Yeah,
me too.
I'll be alright.
Sound sincere.
Ah,
yeah.
All right.
Huh?
I thought you would laugh harder.
Yeah.
Whoa.
You know that was really helping for,
got to agree to disagree on
there's even a debate.
Ah,
please.
Not a one.
My name's Dexter.
And how about
ball hog [inaudible] my name is Sasha and I'm up fall hog
dog.
Yeah,
they're ball hog dogs.
The new porno series.
We're producing dog dick afternoon in the sequel ball hog dogs ball hog dogs.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I really thought you were going to laugh harder at that.
Yeah,
you might like this one.
This is more your speed.
Okay.
Oh fuck yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know my mom,
I don't kill you now.
I don't care what you do and maybe these guys are,
you ain't on twitch,
right?
Well,
your forehead,
they will not fall say fall.
Forehead now trying to run me boat does that day.
The day.
I didn't even know what you're saying.
Mike is dog shit.
Pardon my mic.
You keep talking.
I swear bro.
Man,
I'm sick.
I got to sit here and you know that shit.
That motherfucker funk.
That's something wrong with your downline.
My Brock Hasbro
as funny.
He farted to end the argument.
It's good tactic.
Yeah.
That's a good move to,
that's a palate cleanser for you.
That was great.
That was a nice part.
Sorbet.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You want to watch the other guy jumped off again or know what the jump off the,
no,
I don't want to see any more violent shit.
Like I don't like that,
bro.
I
can't believe you don't find those
screams funny.
Oh my God,
those are great.
Scream Tommy.
What?
It's not for me babe.
It's not for me.
I make life.
I don't destroy it.
Okay.
Such a bummer.
Yeah.
Alright.
Somebody said a,
I think it was maybe even blue ban that this guy made this video and that he
reminds him of my debt.
Oh,
that this is like top dog.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
you hear a lot of things here with us,
Sir David the bark.
I try to be cutting edge information.
I have found a new scientific way to enjoy,
um,
our sex organs now.
Now sit down.
Don't anybody stand up in here?
This is a serious scientific report.
Yeah,
exactly.
A real dad boner.
Yeah,
he does.
Now.
It is coming out of Byu.
No Pun intended.
Huh?
I wish I'd known about this when I was at Byu.
I just knew I was going into outer darkness because I would masturbate and I
thought,
oh my God,
you know,
when we die,
everything we've ever did according to the Mormons are going to be on videotape
and everyone's going to be able to see it.
And I on,
Geez,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a nasty boy.
Any,
anyway,
he definitely has a laugh in the,
he's amuse themselves.
I,
I'm just the like,
okay,
I'm just the reporter.
Don't kill the Messenger.
Okay.
This is called Dick.
D.
I.
C.
K,
which means penis soaking.
Penis.
Oh Wow.
No,
no,
no.
Let's go down here and see if we can find,
here's the urban dictionary.
Okay.
And number one.
Soak in the Mormon faith.
Couples who wish to engage in premarital activities,
but you do not want to dishonor their faith.
Use the Dick soak method.
The [inaudible] method occurs when the males erect a member,
uh,
is placed inside the female vagina and lay still.
Huh?
You dicks in there though.
He said stupid.
Now you know that you've got to talk to the little general about this to go into
battle and lay down in hi.
Hi.
Oh No.
I don't know too many little generals that are going to agree to this.
That was Kinda top dog,
right?
That was very tough.
Dot.
He likes a little general.
She would say that he was like lay still.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This guy.
Yeah,
he's definitely as the,
it's got the innocence of a top down.
Yeah.
I could see it.
Um,
is there anything else Jean?
No.
No,
no.
I can't go lay down.
I was tired.
All right.
Closing Song.
Oh,
there it is.
The open defecation song.
That's the song.
So I guess you get to hear it in its entirety now.
That's why it was here.
All right.
Um,
that is,
uh,
we'll see.
It's a DJ show reference.
Thanks guys.
Thanks mommies.
Okay.
Equine diarrhea,
defecate in the open.
Defecate in the open area.
Quite diarrhea.
Diarrhea,
decline.
I've seen the guy shouldn't Nally sorry guys.
Shit downtown.
Anytime you have the urge to shit,
you would just drop trout,
bro.
Public defecation shitting in public.
It's popping right now.
That's very hobbit.
Diarrhea,
diarrhea,
decline,
diarrhea.
Drop trout.
Trout.
Yeah,
that's urban living.
Trout.
Trout,
trout,
trout.
Oh,
open defecation.
Take two shifts this morning.
Open defecation.
Okay.
Oh,
open defecation.
Really Shit my pants lately.
Oh,
the deprecation.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's
popping right now.
It's like equine diarrhea.
Defecate in the open.
Desiccated,
the open diarrhea,
diarrhea,
equine diarrhea.
Ever Shit outside.
Sorry.
Guy.
Shit downtown.
Anytime you have the urge,
the shit,
you would just drop trout though,
bro.
Public defecation shitting in public.
It's up right now.
That's very hobbit.
You miss 100% of the dicks.
You don't try to stuff in your butt hole.
That's blue,
man.
That's your next project.
Dude.